Once of Palmer Deadpool captain from Marvel movies. We are Marvel
Yeah, you know your Marvel license by Fox. It's like if the Beatles were produced by Nickelback, it's music. It sucks
Okay, that's it
I'm done. I've had it with all this Nickelback hating
alright
You think that makes you cool with the cool kids in school Fred now just makes me write it does it they're over produced?
Formulaic ear or garbage? Oh, really?
You know who might disagree with that?
facts
fifty million albums worldwide
eleventh best-selling musical act of all time
Billboards most successful rock group in the last decade six Grammy nominations twelve Juno Awards those count
Six Billboard Music Awards two American Music Awards one People's Choice Award Canadian and a partridge in a pear tree
Sorry, I
Told you were just having fun. I didn't realize it was I don't you were um
You gotta say you were nicer as a kid
Tired of living like a madman sick aside about a sense of feeling
This is how you remind me
This is how you remind me of what I really am
this is how you remind me of what I really am